[Aplausos]
y también
en tanto de la vida
cómo prepararla
estos planos de la preparatoria
la primera vez que entré al salón de
clases por la fifa de la mañana
era la mente
y para enseñar habilidad
y recuerdo
cuatro animales una vez como tal astilla
como si fuera una mente lógica
estábamos ahí
entonces
maletas culturales
es uno de ellos
pero podemos
y
sí
el próximo año
que agarraba como yo
en otro país como si fuera la propia
y ahora una turista común
qué pasó
no soy yo
aportando
como cualquier joven
y nos lanzamos a alguien
mi propuesta para conocer y entender el
tratamiento cultural de pagar impuestos
mucha gente
si no me dio
cómo
me compré para arriba
más
y me dijo
y contigo
así es
como lo hablan de él
pero sobre todo hay motivación para
aprender
que con una solución de producción
generar nuevas dinámicas
pero esa dinámica
como más bien crear una relación
conflictiva entre nuestros alumnos
y con ellos
bueno
intento exactamente
empezamos conocer los por qué de los
espectadores contratamos de este
proyecto
y
está muy bien de pasado me presenté
por qué
mi alma
exactamente
los primeros 3 millones
pero
algunos se aprendieron hicieron a la
contaminación
para motivarles
dónde
para la mayoría
simplemente no tenemos los ciudadanos lo
que pasa
los de su trabajo
otro tono competido contra toda
latinoamérica
por todas
para una de las historias y para muchas
más
este proyecto cumplió los requisitos
respecto al proyecto integrador
sin embargo qué bien
con el equipo de su navegador
un equipo mexicano
a cambiar el mundo respetando los
objetivos de la gente pobre
pero aquí no empezaron a estudiarlo como
tal aprendiendo con otros proyectos
en lugar de exponer al frente de la zona
en todo lo que sí
como un juego
por eso no quiero que esta página
porque la presentación de esta
experiencia
lo que yo llamo
el segundo
y actuar
el cuarto y el quinto mojado
ninguna propiedad porque hay un
motorista
sensible
por qué
dificultades
para cada colonia benítez
en el mundo con los mundos
precisamente la mañana
es cultural
porque la real en grupo
en la universidad
más hablar porque teniendo ahora
aprender del otro
creo yo
aprendiendo
pero también con ellos
el pasado
no podemos dejar alguna comunicación a
la dinámica del medio ambiente del
silencio
si queremos ayudar el mundo
dónde
y
un puerto grancanario
y vamos a platicar
el que sustituyó todos tenemos
capacidades diferentes pero pocos
en el momento de aprender los ponemos
incómodos
no lo conozco
anteriores
con el conjunto
y ahora
en el recuerdo
la orden
porque la mayoría recordamos
pero como la gente
y otra más
comienzo
los mapas mentales
yo no creo
al final del otoño el proyecto ha
procurado hacer explícito información
este legislador una canción en común
para los arroyos
para cristo
en efectivo con modelos
sólo existen dos culturales
fuera uno de ellos
en el 2000 corrientes y para que
alrededor de 3000
cómo
acción
mi vida
cuando estás agotado
viajamos
no sé
[Aplausos]